professor Feldman did President Trump
commit the impeach able high crime and
misdemeanor of abuse of power based on
that evidence and those findings based
on that evidence in those findings the
President did commit an impeachable
abuse of office
professor Carlin same question same
answer and professor Gerhardt did
President Trump commit the impeachable
high crime and misdemeanor of abuse of
power we three are unanimous I'd like to
quickly now Professor Gerhart does a
high crime and misdemeanor require an
actual statutory crime no there melanne
Lee does not everything we know about
the history of impeachment reinforces
the conclusion that impeachable offenses
do not have to be crimes and again not
all crimes are impeachable offenses and
and professor Turley you recently wrote
in The Wall Street Journal and I quote
there is much that is worthy of
investigation in the Ukraine scandal and
it is true that impeachment doesn't
require a crime that's true but I also
added an important caveat first of all
here it was a yes or a no question did
you write in the Wall Street Journal
there is much that is worthy of
investigation in the Ukraine scandal and
it is true that impeachment does not
require crime is that an accurate quote
sir
that's the read well professor Gerhart
what is your view I of course agree
professor Carlin professor Feldman and I
just want to stress that if this what
we're if what we're talking about is not
impeachable then nothing is impeachable
this is precisely the misconduct that
the framers created a constitution
including impeachment to protect against
and if there's no action if we if
Congress to concludes they're going to
give a pass to the president here is
Professor Carlin suggested
every other precedent the president will
say okay then I can do the same thing
and the boundaries will just evaporate
and those boundaries are set up by the
Constitution and we may be witnessing
unfortunately their erosion and that is
a danger to all of us foment
disagreement among the American people
and the very idea that a president might
seek the aid of a foreign government in
his re-election campaign would have
horrified them but based on the
evidentiary record that is what
President Trump has done well because
this is an abuse that cuts to the heart
of democracy you need to ask yourselves
if you don't impeach a president who has
done what this president has done or at
least you don't you don't investigate
and then impeach if you conclude that
the house that the House Select
Committee on Intelligence findings are
correct then what you're saying is it's
fine to go ahead and do this again
and I think that as the you know in the
in the report that came out last night